you can take your job next
perhaps this guy from the futuristic
video game was a lawyer once upon a time
and then the world's first robot lawyer
do not pay appeared and has already been
dubbed the Robin Hood of the internet
for example last year this AI
successfully challenged 160
000 parking fines so far it's only
handling minor offenses but it's making
legal help more accessible for everyone
Joshua Browder CEO of do not pay and
chose to take a case to the courtroom
using his robot lawyer the AI was
supposed to tell the defendant exactly
how he should defend himself but legal
professionals were not happy with this
suggestion at all
foreign
[Music]
who would you trust a human lawyer or a
machine tell us in the comments and
don't forget to subscribe